mesdames messieurs et guérillas suspense
extraordinaire au parc des princes où le
psg et saint-etienne sont à égalité 2 à
2 en ce moment procède à l'épreuve des
penalties
tout de suite nous retrouvons kiri
rolland pour nous commenter en direct
ces derniers penalty eh bien oui la
première série de penalty vient de se
terminer
battiston hannon rep lario c'est platini
ont marqué pour saint-etienne alors que
bathenay renault rocheteau sur jacques
et fernandez marquer eux pour le
l'équipe de paris saint germain et on
est en train de procéder actuellement à
la désignation des tireurs pour la
deuxième série de penalty alors que le
président de la république aux côtés du
président de la fédération tout de même
au parc des princes depuis trois heures
et quart ils ne s'attendaient
certainement pas à passer une ve soirée
aussi longue
au stade d'auteuil toujours est il que
nous avons vécu un match assez
extraordinaire une deuxième mi-temps
dirais-je surtout assez extraordinaire
puisque à la mi temps le score était nul
de 0 à 0 puis toko ouvert la marque pour
paris saint-germain la 57e minute
platini égalisant à la 76e minute
on devait donc jouer la prolongation et
au cours de la prolongation platini une
nouvelle fois donne l avantage à
l'équipe stéphanoise rocheteau égalisant
à la toute dernière seconde de la partie
ou non le stade était envahi par une
bande d'énergumènes que je préfère ne
pas qualifier
voici lopez qui tire donc le sixième
penalty et le rap
le fais
raté c'était pour arras et lille vient
d'arrêter un penalty de lopez le
capitaine
de l'équipe de saint-etienne
et maintenant si le parisien qui vient
marc hé bien les parisiens auront
remporté cette finale de la coupe de
france avec la chance d'avoir attelly
milan fait faux bond il arrête avec ces
gens voyant se lançant quand même du bon
côté alors que le président borelli
alors que le président borelli et sur le
terrain
c'est fini
paris saint germain a remporté la coupe
de france car si penalty à cinq
et c'est du délire vous le voyez autour
du président du paris saint-germain tous
les joueurs s'embrassent paris
saint-germain disputera donc la saison
prochaine la coupe d'europe des
vainqueurs de coupes
alors que dominique bathenay dans
quelques instants va recevoir
va recevoir des mains du président de la
république la 65e coupe de france
dernier penalty
6e réussit par pilorget alors que lopez
avait raté le sien
faut dire que dans cette épreuve des
penaltys il ya eu quelques suspense là
aussi puisque le premier penalty pour
paris saint germain était tiré par
bathenay qui envoyait la balle nettement
au dessus de monsieur vautrot
l'excellent arbitre de cette finale
donnée à rejouer
parce que le gardien avait bougé alors
que nous revoyons ici les buts du match
et le premier but de la partie réussi
par djoko à la 57e minute pendant 20
minutes exactement 19 minutes les
parisiens vont garder cet avantage à la
marque c'est à dire qu'ils auront dix
ont une main sur la coupe de france la
défense stéphanoise étant la frise
complètement à revers par ce centre en
retrait de sur jacques et la reprise de
popo 1 à 0 donc pour paris saint germain
mais platini dans cete les adieux au
public du parc des princes égalisait à
la 76e minute
remettant les deux équipes à égalité et
les forçant donc à jouer la prolongation
deux mi temps d'un quart d'heure au
cours de cette prolongation
les stéphanois faisaient le plus souvent
le jeu on sentait plus de maturité chez
les verts que dans l'équipe parisienne
il faisait peut-être mieux circuler le
ballon ces stéphanois et
obtenir ce qu'ils pensaient peut-être le
gain du match
encore une fois par leur extraordinaire
numéro 10 michel platini 2 1 on jouait
les toutes dernières secondes de la
partie lorsque michel le nomme
s'échappait sur l'ailé droite adressait
un centre
avant que la balle ne revienne assure
jacques qui lui centrait et dominique
rocheteau du point de penalty on fait
jean castaneda ce qui permet à dominique
bathenay de recevoir des mains du
président de la république et en direct
maintenant la 65e coupe de france c'est
la quatrième coupe de france que gagne
dominique bathenay puisqu'il l'avait
enlevée déjà à trois reprises avec
saint-etienne précisément ce qui lui
vaut une tape amicale du président
rocher c'est un jour de gloire je crois
pour l'équipe de paris saint germain
car c'était évidemment la première
finale du grand club parisien mais
surtout surtout c'est le premier titre
remporté par ce club mais il y a
seulement dix ans et c'est la première
fois depuis 1949 tenez vous bien qu'une
équipe de la capitale remporte la coupe
de france
c'est donc vraiment un très très grand
jour non seulement je crois pour le
paris saint germain vous voyez la joie
des joueurs bien sympathique mais c'est
un jour de gloire je crois surtout pour
le football parisien paris saint germain
n'a pas volé cette coupe loin de là même
s'il a été obtenu au penalty